[Music]
divorce creates a lot of stress and
brings up a lot of questions regarding
what families will look like after the
split that's the topic of
the topic of discussion with eric
palacios in today's edition of la vegas
now
so in the divorce process one of the
biggest questions that couples have is
what happens to the children who do they
go with and how is that time split
great question and a lot of us may think
that
the mom has a preference especially if
the children are are very young
we oftentimes think that mom is the the
better parent to raise a baby and tell
their toddlers
but the court has taken a different
stance nowadays they start with a 50 50
equal division of time so dad has just
as much right
to to young babies as the mother does uh
if one of the parents wants additional
time
with the children or more time than the
other then they have to prove to the
court
that this is in the best interest of the
child so in such a case
what determines the best interest of a
child
a lot of different factors how is the
situation at home
does the child have their own bedroom do
they have to share with a lot of
siblings with new step
siblings how is the situation with a new
step
dad step mom schooling is it easy for
them to get to school is it convenient
who's going to
drop them off pick them up so a lot of
different factors go into play in
deciding what's in their best interest
things can get especially complicated if
one parent wants to move
out of state how does that work when it
comes to child custody
if they have sole custody it's not too
difficult but majority of
parents have shared custody and then it
does become
a fight if one of the parents does not
want to allow this to happen they can
say no
then the parent that wants to take the
child out of state has to go to court
uh and explain to the judge how this
will not negatively affect
the child a lot of times the court finds
that it is negative
uh negative change for the children and
mom or dad has to leave the state
without the kids
and change custody to only around
holidays or
maybe some additional time in the summer
so before
uh deciding to move out of state uh it's
important to talk to your attorney
and see what the possibilities are of uh
taking your children
with you and making this a seamless
transition
eric palacios always good to talk to you
appreciate your time
thank you for having me we'll see you
soon all right for more information give
eric palacios and associates a call at
that number 702 702-444-7777
or you can visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com
we'll be